MARK MIRCHANDANI: With almost
500 sessions at Next 2019,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see best
practices, GCP resource
organization, and
access management,
then stay tuned, because
here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Regardless if you're
new to Google Cloud
Platform or a
longtime user, it's
important to keep all your
GCP resources organized.
We don't just mean
resources like VMs,
but actually at the project
and organization level.
In this talk, Max
and Greg go over
what these different resources
are and best practices
for organizing them.
It's important to consider
the setup since almost a third
of billing support cases
that we handle end up being
resource management related.
If you're not sure how your
resources are configured,
you may find yourself dealing
with confusing invoices, access
issues, or even potential
disruption of service.
The best way to
avoid these issues is
to make sure everything is
set up to match your needs.
Let's take a look at
the resource hierarchy.
Here's an overview of
the different resources.
We'll step into each area and
talk about different things
to consider.
Your domain and organization
are like an umbrella
for everything in the cloud.
The domain is done through
G Suite or Cloud Identity,
and helps you manage users.
Organizations let you manage
all of the GCP resources
through the console.
Together, these make sure you
have a way to manage everything
from a high level, especially
helpful for situations
when someone may have
lost access to a low level
resource like a project.
You'll have a super
admin for the domain
and an organizational admin
for your organization, which
could be the same person.
Make sure to consider who should
be the admin in each case,
such as the org
admin being a more
senior technical member
in charge of all the cloud
projects.
It's also key to make
sure everyone knows
who the admins for these are
and to keep all the rolls up
to date.
Try to aim for a reasonable
level of redundancy
to avoid any single
points of failure.
Billing accounts are under
the organization and control
how you pay for anything
the associated projects use.
They have their own set
of roles and permissions,
such as the billing
account users,
who can see how much each
project is spending and link
projects to a billing account.
Only a billing account
admin can remove projects
from the billing
account and set budgets.
Again, it's important to know
who your billing admin is,
because they're needed
if you ever want
to contact billing support.
In most cases, you'll only
need one billing account
per organization,
which will also
help keep things simple
when looking at what
you're paying per project.
Don't forget to enable BigQuery
Export as soon as possible,
so you can further analyze
what you're paying for.
Now, the payments profile
actually sits outside the cloud
and is used for paying anything
in Google, such as Chrome
licenses.
You may want to have the same
admin for both your payments
profile and your
billing account.
But you can customize who has
access to edit information
or only have read only access.
Just like your billing account,
we typically recommend only
having one payment profile.
Making sure the right
people have access
and getting notifications
can go a long way
in avoiding any fire drills.
You should also add a
secondary payment method
and review the roles
here on a regular basis
to avoid any potential problems.
Anything done in
GCP will be done
from a project,
which are basically
like groupings of
direct cloud resources,
such as Kubernetes clusters.
These projects can exist under
folders as well as be labeled,
so you have full customization
over your hierarchy.
In fact, we recommend
trying to match
your company's environment.
So maybe you'd have a
folder for each team
or different folders
for dev and prod.
You should use
naming conventions
that are familiar to your
team for projects and labels,
so everyone knows what
each project is for.
Labels can help
group those together.
Each project also has
its own role management,
so you can ensure only
trusted people can
edit resources
inside of a project
or even create new projects.
This is a quick overview
of the resource hierarchy,
but there's plenty more
specifics and best practices
to check out, which you can
read through in the guide
and checklist linked here.
Max and Greg go into a
deeper dive for each area
during the talk, cover
more best practices,
and walk through
an example of what
a company might consider for
their resources as they grow.
If you'd like to
see the full talk,
check out the link in
the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube channel
for more great "Next
Rewind" content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]